Danny Meyer built his restaurant empire
by focusing on good food and what he
calls enlightened hospitality Meyer is
the founder of the burger joint Shake
Shack some of the best burgers in the
world the popular fast casual chain has
178 locations worldwide
he's also CEO of Union Square
Hospitality Group which owns 17 New York
area restaurants four of those now
operate completely cashless and Meyer
says more will follow now this is not
the first time he's made some innovative
moves in 2015 Meyer established a
hospitality included policy and got rid
of tipping at several restaurants Danny
Meyer joins us once again at the table
all right Danny Meyer people always say
you're ahead of the curve so now you're
going cassius at your place is why well
for those places of ours that are going
cashless which are now for the reason
it's primarily security for our staff
when you have cash on premise you're
only inviting problems you're inviting
potential problems from the outside
you're also inviting potential problems
from the inside it also creates speed
it's more efficient it's more efficient
it's also believe it or not especially
and I'm not talking about the fine
dining restaurants for so few people use
cash anyway but in a fast casual or fine
casual restaurant the more people
handling cash and handling your food
also can lead to some sanitary issues
well the pushback I've heard though is
that people that don't have credit cards
or bank account or or a bank account
that it sort of excludes that that type
of clientele well I wish our restaurants
were so inexpensive that people who
can't get credit cards could also afford
either I'm just kidding about that
yeah but we're sensitive to that and we
had to weigh that because the last thing
we want to do is be exclusionary we're a
hospitality business and at the end of
the day we said that most people these
days are either using apps or they're
using credit cards or they're using
loyalty cards and they don't even want
to have pennies and nickels jangling in
their pockets if somebody absolutely
says I'm dying to eat you know one of
your tacos at taco xena but I don't have
a credit card we're gonna probably find
a way to take care of them anyway but I
think when you have an overarching
philosophy about it you definitely make
the place safer for everybody who works
there
danni including being in an incredible
restaurant tour you also seem to be able
to get ahead of political issues before
they sort of strike you see
Massachusetts bars restaurants from
being cashless and other businesses you
see this now in the DC City Council is
saying no we're gonna ban restaurants
and other companies from doing that it's
also happening in the city of Chicago
what would you tell legislators who want
to tell businesses like you know you
can't be completely cashless I would say
I'm glad you're a legislator and I'm
glad I'm a hospitality guy because I
just I feel like there is a genuine
issue and I really do understand this
this question I have friends who go
traveling and they don't want to get the
credit card fee for the you know for the
exchange rate I get that but at the end
of the day we're only in business if we
have people who are happy to come to
work and if people feel like they're not
safe because there's so much cash on
premise it's not ultimately a good thing
I also think that our society is moving
away from cash I even think that wallets
are going to go away one of these days
if we could if we could rely upon
biometrics my eyes tell you everything
you need to know about me my table
preference you know my allergies my
credit card information it's a few has
there been a big uptick in crime related
to cashiers has just always been an
ongoing challenge with restaurants and
so why not give nothing new today that
we haven't seen for years but but it's
always been an issue and you have you
tried this experiment anywhere to see
get feedback on how this works with
customers we have we're doing it right
now at four of our places one of them is
daily provisions here in New York
one is Martina and one is taka Sina and
how many instances have there been where
people say I don't have any cash there's
been a handful as a matter of fact I had
an investment banker come up to me a
couple days ago and say you know what I
left my credit card at home he actually
had a credit card what's his name on
your that big one that you know what he
said what he said you know why I love
your places so much I left my credit
card at home and they said don't worry
about it
and he came back the next day to pay and
they said don't worry about it the day
before we go though Danny there's a bar
to you there is a big story in the news
about Sarah Sanders being rejected being
asked to leave a restaurant how would
you handle that situation is that
something that you would have done or
anyone at your staff would have done I'd
like to think that the people we hired
our restaurants are there for the
purpose of hospitality I'm benefiting
from having grown up with a Republican
dad and a Democratic mom yeah and we use
the dinner table to talking these out
how do you I think it's a slippery slope
how do you know that Sarah Sanders or
someone wasn't dining with a liberal
friend and they were gonna use the table
as an opportunity to work things out if
she said she was a liberal family member
doesn't surprise me so you know what
look if the minute you see me checking
people's political registration at the
door mm-hmm that's that's a bad future I
think for our business all right Danny
Meyer I expected that answer from you
thank you sir can't wait to go to your
new place thanks a lot